let's let's i got to read this story all
right this one this one is is near and
dear to my heart yes when i saw the
story i was like i don't want to talk
about comics and i read it and i was
like
bounding into comics says dc comics
retcon sees static received powers
during black
lives matter protest okay first i was
just like all right
well you know it's a modern retelling of
a comic book story black lives matter
can be relevant to this
and then i read the the the panels they
include
and i'm just like this is really bad
it's really good
so uh i don't know if i need to
necessarily read the uh
let's read a little bit they say a
recent retcon to the origin story of the
dc comic superhero static
real identity virgil hawkins has changed
the inciting incident that grants him
superpowers from a gang war
to a black lives matter protest okay
there is so much wrong with this
i'll i'll need to actually read the
comic to give you a better breakdown
but let me just explain something in the
original in the original comic
he's basically he's a good kid but he's
being bullied
he gets a gun and he shows up at this
gang war and he wants to take out his
bull he wants to kill his bully
but he decides he can't do it he starts
crying and he throws the gun into the
water
but then the police seeing a gang war
you know people are trying to kill each
other
fire and experimental tear gas which
caused some crazy reaction they call it
the big bang and then also
all these gang bangers get super powers
well guess what these are not good
people right
turns out they become super villains but
this kid who was down there who actually
was an okay kid just mixed up in some
bad stuff
ends up becoming a hero in the in the
more in the later version
the more recent version it's the stall
all still pretty old
the wb cartoon static shock he basically
gets pressured into joining
he doesn't want to join so i thought
that was a really awesome way to deal
with issues that
i know exactly what that was like
growing on the growing up on the south
side of chicago i knew people
who were surrounded by people and gangs
who were like are you joining or not you
have you know you have to join you live
in our area
and then it's called veed you get veed
in you get violated
and so what they do is they would beat
the crap out of these kids who are like
14 or 15 force them to join gangs
one dude went to prison because what
they want to do is they want to get a
minor
give them a gun and say go and kill our
enemies because you'll get out in four
years because they can't hold you until
you're 18. so
when i saw this show i was like wow
that's that's clever right
it actually gets to you know like real
issues that i think affect young people
they don't want to get mixed up in this
stuff it addresses social justice issues
in a really cool way and it actually
told an interesting story
there's a chemical explosion the people
who are there happen to be mostly gang
bangers
mostly become super villains now this
kid who gets mixed up in it
he's like i didn't want to be here in
the first place i'm going to do good i'm
gonna try and be
better my question now is in the in the
new version
they're all at a black lives matter
protest right and for no reason
the police start shooting them with tear
gas so in this comic
the cop says you know who do they think
they are turn around and get back to
school or be arrested for truancy and
then someone yells
stop killing innocent people and we will
someone holding a sign that says she was
sleeping
fine then let them fly says the cop as
they start shooting this tear gas at the
crowd
almost instantly one dude's skin starts
melting off
and the cop is like is that kid's face
melting and then all of a sudden they
all have superpowers
so like this is the story the cops fire
tear gas at a random group of black
lives matter protesters they all get
through powers i got a question about
this
where did the villains come from well i
guess that'd be the police in this
scenario
sting copeland all of them well no
i mean they are they are they are
portraying the cops of the bad guys but
gotta be right
but what i mean is the cops in the in
the uh comic are wearing gas masks
in the original version it was gang
bangers getting gassed yeah
and so naturally many of these people
are not good people become villains what
do they say what do they say the
villains do come
from i don't know it just it just says
he's like i got powers
but hold on here's the funny thing he
says here's what it says he goes uh uh
i don't i don't know what the first
panel is it's just him waking up saying
which made me stronger stronger than i
could ever imagine that electricity
burst from his eyes
now i could get revenge on all the
bullies who picked on me
who pick on everybody but it turns out
they have powers too
and it's three white dudes and it's like
blonde
and they're bullies one guy's like
shirts ripping she's all ripped one
guy's fist is on fire they have the
protesters
and i'm just like essentially three biff
from uh back to the yeah
exactly but does this mean they were
also protesting for black lives matter
yeah why were they there because they
wouldn't be there like protesting
against it
oh but yeah maybe that's it they were
there yeah
they needed antifa there they were also
violent protesters that then became
villains but instead they they framed
the cops they had all bullies lives
matters
i wonder if like the angle they're going
for is that the bullies are bad guys and
they're like we're gonna rob this bank
and then he's like you're at the black
lives matter protest too but you're a
villain well well hold on we may be
villains but we all agree black lives
matter right
right so that's the angle they're going
for well of course the villains were
there even the villains agree
yeah it's almost like they chose this uh
topic but it was so sensitive that they
had to sort of uh
illogically decide kind of the rest of
the plot line
i just i i'm just a train wreck i should
have i should have expected
that you know this is the angle they
would go but it really does feel
like cheap i'm not trying to be mean to
black lives matter or anything i mean
you know we've talked about them quite a
bit i've been critical of
over the riots but like you one of the
biggest problems with
star wars latest iterations and like
captain marvel and a lot of these new
comics
is that it's just really cheap writing
it's not clever it's not good it's not
interesting it's just really obvious
like it's a dude sitting there with his
eyes half closed and he's like i don't
know he's a black lives matter protest
or something
just write it down and sell it whatever
you know like it used to be
that whenever you're getting propaganda
period
the hope is that it's good enough that
you'll take your propaganda like i'll be
watching certain shows
and you can kind of tell when it's
really getting into that stuff and
they're trying to sell you something you
go okay and then there's another one
where the show sucks and you're like hey
there's 12 characters and 11 of them are
gay and you're like
this isn't good enough for how much
you're shoving this down my face
so i think the problem is yeah it's it's
like anything in any art
or songs you know anything you're
listening to it's like
you get to give me a teaspoon of
propaganda per good amount of
entertainment
right right and then i think that they
are tipping the scales where the
the propaganda levels are out of the out
of the
ballpark but i mean like even so i bet
the
the argument from the left will be the
original static shot cartoon
was very much social justicey but it was
the
like the liberal kind i mean i mean like
philosophically liberal
where it was just hey man don't be mean
to somebody for no reason don't be
racist
now it's just like this seems like what
do they call it
um they call it rainbow washing when you
just make something
you know lgbtq to sell a product it's
kind of like social justice wash and
they're like oh
that is that's static so i think there's
probably so much logistical things too
it's the same thing that happened with
you know recently we were talking about
even this is on amazon but i'm sure you
guys cover like potato and all that
stuff but it's like
they basically were like oh there's an
easy way to kind of get clicks and this
your new advertising campaign comes in
and they go yo all you have to do is
this
but then now even on that side they go
hey you didn't do it right and then the
other side gets mad at them so
i think in a lot of ways the the like
easy bucks to be made of social justice
are becoming harder and harder so you
know what i mean they're like oh we'll
we'll do this everyone will like it you
got extra extra virgin olive oil you got
extra virgin olive oil and you got
virgin and you got olive oil
and so it's like the very last drop
being yeah they're trying to squeeze out
the last drop of money that you can get
from you know saying you've got the
right opinions
so i think when you do this it's like i
think that you probably end up making a
lot of decisions and choices
based on things other than what makes
sense for your plot probably
have you guys seen the new craft movie
no it's called the craft right now i
think you've talked about it yeah are
the witches
yeah the witches bro if you want
material you should watch the craft
yeah i'm progressive i only support male
witches because i think that well
you'll love it because there's one in
the movie yeah of course they they
basically i'm
a spoiler alert for anybody who plans on
seeing this movie they there's a bully
and they cast a spell to turn him gay i
guess
i think that's what happens and then he
gets murdered for being gay or they
didn't cast a spell and he's like it was
a spell right you know
his girlfriend's like what happened he's
freaking witches man
why are you blowing a dude have you
heard of witches
[Laughter]
now everybody's listening will have a
clever excuse if they ever need to use
them
[Laughter]
but his dad's a witch yeah his dad's a
male witch yeah
so so anyway the witch is like break
into his house
and then like they steal some of his you
know man
uh uh uh what which i call it
reproductive
fluids and then cast a spell on him to
make him nice and then he like becomes a
gay i guess
so then his dad has to kill him or
something the whole movie
it's not a movie yeah i mean fair enough
your dad does have to kill you yeah
it goes without saying the movie is the
movie is basically just like
uh awoke psa and i'm watching it like
waiting for a story to happen is not
there
yeah but i mentioned that but there's
also i was watching waiting for the gay
sex scene and it never came either so
both of us were disappointed
yeah yeah no yeah yeah so you're
disappointed for other reasons there's
another movie called spiral
and this one is oh man we i think we
talked about this in one of the tim cast
segments
so you know what shutter is at shutter
like
shuu ddr it's a it's a subscription
service for horror shows and movies no i
love hor i love horror it's like my
favorite genre i love
you know the uh what is that what does
that move in the cold game and the
others
yeah i think that movie's awesome that
movie's great and i love old 80s movies
i just watched the stuff have you ever
seen it
no it's where people start eating trash
out of the ground
but then it turns out it's like you know
a lot of gutter funks it's what
they're eating people yeah so so this
shutter has this film called
spiral and it starts
with an interracial gay couple who have
a daughter
and then they moved to a new town no i'm
fine i don't i don't care about that i
don't i don't care about static being a
black lives matter protest i care about
the story making sense
how are you going to have super villains
if like how are the bullies
were they the black lives matter
protests like what's going on i guess
right
so anyway i'm watching this movie and
i'm like i didn't i didn't really think
twice about the interracial gay couple
being
you know the characters i was just like
it's 20 20 man you know i was like
whatever
but then very early on you get a glimpse
of what the movie is
i'm just gonna spoil the whole movie for
everybody if you're a subscriber to
shudder well you know too bad
witches witches it turns out switches
again there are immortal white people
who explain that they choose minority
and marginalized families on purpose
to frame for murders so that they can
sacrifice them for immortality
and then in the end the bad guy is like
there will always be people to fear
and no one will ever believe you
and i'm like you gotta be kidding me
dude like like you said
you can give me a teaspoon of propaganda
for every you know every cup of
entertainment i get that was the whole
thing was propaganda i liked uh
the 100 i like i honestly thought that
show was kind of good but
by the end they so everyone's a lesbian
right
one of those shows like all the all the
everyone all the leaders are women and
they're all lesbians
and all of the women are the best
fighters and it's sort of like a sci-fi
thing but then they give the backstory
and they just came on a spaceship and
there's like
they don't give you any logistical
reason why
in this world the women like it's not oh
they're like amazonian women it's just
like normal women
and for some reason the women are better
fighters than guys they don't explain
you go okay whatever
yeah you just have to be like i want i
watch these fight scenes better be sweet
dude
i watched a really good there's a video
explaining why captain america
and captain marvel are like totally
different captain america is good
everyone loves it captain marvel like
people kind of like
groaned at it and kind of just accepted
it and
they explained that one of the issues is
you know like early on in captain
america they explained to you
steve rogers captain america's a weak
guy he's weak but he's willing to stand
up he's a scrawny dude getting beat up
outside of a theater
and it establishes yeah they have to
give you that like establish your world
i'll believe your world but you just
have to give me an explanation even if
the explanation's stupid they go
oh he stepped in a puddle that gave him
this you go okay like he's just right
otherwise you go it doesn't make sense
but your context but in this in this
context what they're basically saying is
you know who steve rogers is he's not
the strongest guy
but he's willing to stand up and defend
himself no matter what with and then he
eventually
gets super powers and then you see this
guy of really good moral character who
wants to protect people
now is powerful and says i'm gonna do
the right thing whereas captain marvel
is
she's always strong she's always been
the best and the man like there's a guy
yeah there's no they've completely uh
removed themselves from any hero's
journey
all of these like women power movies
basically became steven seagal movies
where there's no adversity
like they start out and she's just like
oh ready to kick sometimes
and then she goes beats up everyone and
then you know it's like
there's there's no even point where she
wasn't going to potentially make it
this is this is the problem i guess with
modern
the modern version of i guess gen z
storytelling it's probably millennials
who are writing these comics but think
about this
if if you've got let's take a look at
the black lives matter narrative right
they're doing a comic where they're like
telling the cops you're killing innocent
people
well that's a gross oversimplification
of what's happening the cops are
immediately the bad guys who fire on
them for no reason
in captain marvel she's actually the bad
guy
in in the beginning of the movie some
guy in a motorcycle tells her to smile
so she steals his clothes and his
motorcycle and presumably just leaves
him like nude in a parking lot
wow yeah that's like when that happened
i was kind of like dude i don't want to
root for this character some guy made a
snide comment so she robbed
the reason for it like i i find this
even when i'm writing stuff and
especially when i was like doing more
traditional stuff
there is this thing of like you're not
supposed to say this about this person
you're not supposed to say this but this
but like
so if you're gonna make people
protagonists they need
you know bad qualities and good
qualities but there's this sort of thing
like if you're gonna write a woman
they're like oh we'll make her shitty
and you're like
well you can't make women bad like
that's bad for women we're just gonna
make a
woman character and like yeah here's our
hero she's like can't critically think
uh you know no you're like what do you
mean you can't make we need strong women
characters with no flaws
well that's that's well that's not
really a good story that there's no
flaws
think about do you see what happened
with wmx in the other day no but how
about that for uh
that's how i get my superpowers is i'm
at the women's march
when some yes i love it yeah some of the
police fire tear gas at them
yes for no reason police fired tear gas
at the women but it didn't i didn't need
it it turns out
well they thought they fired tear gas
turns out they were just already crying
oh my gosh the whole women and it was
their it was their love for the fellow
man that granted them superpowers
yeah yeah that's what it was so i'll
tell you the one last thing that this is
a joke but i said that
and how what happened to the women's
march is they all march from one side of
the city and halfway through they forget
something and go back
and that's it they gave their problems
yeah they all forget something and at
the end it was their superpowers and i
donated money to the women's march i
hope they find a cure
okay okay all right so so do you see
that
do you see you see the whimx with twitch
no tell me about this twitch put out a
video where they were like
we we want all wemmicks in to be
supported oh yeah yeah no of course
and the left got really mad it was like
yeah they got fired up and then they had
issued an apology being like are bad
yeah we didn't realize that you know
calling you wimmicks and we thought it
was inclusive
you're making this very hard to pander
to you right now but think about that
think about they're like okay we're
gonna make a movie we want to get
feminists and women to come watch so
let's do the hero's journey
and they're going through the script and
they're like let's make it very much
like captain america everyone loved that
one
well we can't make her weak correct like
steve rogers was a scrawny weak guy in
the beginning
okay well we'll just have her be strong
but how do we then establish
her journey amnesia she's always strong
but she has amnesia that's what they did
that's the most
that's the movie and then they do this
thing where they're like okay what's her
conflict
her achilles heel five thousand dollar
purses
i think that's the only that's her
tonight the men keep telling her to
control her emotions
oh i'm not kidding that's the movie
she's always strong
she gets amnesia and the guy says you're
too emotional and at the end
she like uses her emotions and says
something like i can do whatever i want
i guess
but so the point i'm making is they
could not make a flawed female character
out of fear that they'll get ripped
apart by the woke left like
look you say wimmix and thinking you're
pandering to them and you're actually
insulting them
there's no right way to address it i
think the trans people got kind of fired
up about that one too they did
understand well count dankula had
probably the best response
he said imagine fighting your whole life
to transition and to be considered a
woman
and then these woke corporations just
come out and tell you you're not
like and then all these woke leftists
were like dankula redemption arc
and he's like no i've always felt that
way like yeah acting like it's a
different opinion but then he did show
the second
video of his dog so the black lives
matter one yeah it was it was worse than
that
i love that one yeah thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you